signore e signori visto il successo
incredibile che ha avuto più episodi di
vostri video a casa ho deciso di fare un
altro episodio come dice stesso ragazzi
chi non muore non risponda andiamo a
vedere quali sono stati i vostri video
in questa settimana fatti in casa
vi ricordo ragazzi che se volete
partecipare basta che mi andiate sulla
mail fa vj video a casa a chiocciola
gmail.com questa qua
guardiamo il primo ragazzi ma opinion
claps action began
ma cosa ho visto ma cosa ho visto cosa
ho visto vi prego uno shop section va
bene per fare questo e come io faccio
attività fisica però bello il poster che
c'hai bellissimo è incredibile che la
tua maglia faccia pandan col mio
pantalone in this moment fantastico raga
abbiamo aumentato l'asticella quamar o
l'asticella da pallavolo l'asticella
vera l'ha ucciso cioè io non so come sia
possibile questa cosa e morto il bambino
ma poi con che soddisfazione guarda la
fascia me è proprio soddisfatta aver
fatto sta cosa va bene
[Musica]
oggi gli zii using the guitar chi dozens
la batki di the news e pixo almost epic
prossimo partecipante voglio morire
adesso dio prendimi bella l'intenzione
aspetta che ne ho altri la mia vita l'ho
presa e l'ho buttata nel cesso nel cesso
perfetto cosa che cazzo è successo c'era
ritmo ma cosa fai
cos'è sta roba cosa vi stipendi scusa
cosa era sta cosa spiegami che poi otto
ore per fare e io non lo sto ragazzo
avrà sfruttate la mia voce su tik tok e
ragazzi che vi devo dire ormai è
patrimonio di tik tok la mia voce pro
bravi mi piacete beh direi
[Musica]
ecco grande perfetto bellissimo
bellissimo il finale regalano fermi
finale da oscar meraviglioso se va bene
stai giocando col quadro ma neanche
[Risate]
bellissimo mi piace perché ha usato la
canzone di app che è il mio film
d'animazione preferito tranne ward che
effettivamente quello che ho doppiato io
che uscirà tra poco al cinema ragazza
allora siete qui per assistere a una
sinfonia di beethoven ma tocca a me ne
frega un cazzo
ora deve vendere bene tipo
[Musica]
cioè io la chiusa zia non devono anche
forlì in montaggio hard
basta
[Musica]
ace
non mentre questa parte giampiero
[Musica]
copyright queste copyright si è una
canzone con il copyright i sì esatto e
copy right una canzone con il copyright
il comparto una cosa è copyright
copyright ok va bene
ovviamente non farò mai
devi stare calmo non farò mai
ho detto che devi stare gavi altra madre
di base non farò mai del non farò mai
non farò bravo bellissima questa secondo
me l'aria parlata di tik tok che
dovrebbe andare di più non quella
dell'altra volta questa è pazzesca
bravissimo comunque vediamo il prossimo
che cazzo ti fa alla space madama pur da
madonna a porta a porta
ma spiega ma da burt ma poi è scappata
c'è non è che dici vabbè è proprio
scappata
ok ho visto episodio di palloni di
pallavolo fanno sono da anni però va beh
signori miei questo erano i vostri video
da casa spero che video vi sia piaciuto
avete migliorato rispetto al primo
episodio molto bravi molto bravi state
squillando sono curiosi di vedere nel
terzo episodio cosa tirerete fuori a
questo punto iscrivervi al canale
mandatemi video e alla mail come vi ho
detto prima felice i video a casa che
oggi mail.com schiacciatela campanellina
qua sotto prima nel aggiornati su nei
video che è strano che veniva
le notifiche perché sennò non vi
arrivano e no ai signori come sempre ci
vediamo a un prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]